L
SUFFER.
THE FORMER DEPUTY DHS SECRETARY
JOINS US.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE CARTELS,
KEN, THIS WOULD NEVER HAVE
HAPPENED AT A NORMAL FUNCTIONING
WORKPLACE, IF SOMEONE ON THE
STAFF SENDS THE BOSS SOMETHING
THAT TOTALLY CONTRADICTS
SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPENING, HE
DOESN'T GO OUT THERE AND
CONTINUE TO LIE.
HE TELLS THE TRUTH AND HE TELLS
HIS BOSS THE TRUTH.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
WHAT WENT WRONG HERE?
>> NO, IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
JESSE, LET ME ANTICIPATE THE
EXCUSE.
HE'S GOING TO SAY, "WELL, I
DIDN'T SEE THAT EMAIL."
I GUARANTEE YOU, IF THE
SECRETARY IS HEADED TO A WHITE
HOUSE PRESS CONFERENCE AND GETS
AN EMAIL FROM THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM 2.5 HOURS
BEFORE, THAT EMAIL IS READ BY
SECRETARY MAYORKAS HIMSELF.
THEY DON'T LET HIM OUT VERY
OFTEN.
I CAN TELL YOU HOW THIS PROCESS
WORKS.
I ANTICIPATE THAT LIE IS COMING,
BUT I WOULD BE SHOCKED --
SHOCKED -- IF HE HAD NOT READ
THAT BEFORE HE WENT UP AND SAID
EVERYTHING YOU JUST SHOWED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AGAIN.
HE LIED THROUGH HIS TEETH.
HE THREW THE PEOPLE HE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR, NOT JUST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, BUT THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR HIM, PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE, UNDER THE
BUS.
AND KNOWINGLY.
IT WASN'T -- YOU KNOW, IT WASN'T
CASUAL.
HE KNEW WHAT HE WAS DOING WHEN
HE DID IT.
IN MY VIEW, THIS IS IMPEACHABLE.
IT ISN'T THE ONLY IMPEACHABLE
ACT BY HIM.
>> Jesse: THIS IS ONE OF MANY.
FORGET ABOUT THE EMAIL.
JUST LOOK THE AT THE BORDER.
TALK ABOUT THE BORDER.
THE VIDEO WE JUST SHOWED, THIS
IS HEAVY ARTILLERY.
THESE GUYS ARE TAXED UP,
STRAPPED UP.
>> MILITARY WEAPONRY.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
THIS IS A HOP, SKIP AND JUMP
FROM TEXAS, THE UNITED.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO HERE?
>> WE NEED TO TAKE CONTROL OF
THE BORDER AND NOT -- NOT ALHAN
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS SECURE
BORDER, BUT REALLY SECURE IT.
I HAVE PUT OUT A ENTIRE LIST OF
PROPOSALS ABOUT HOW TO GO AFTER
THIS PROBLEM, SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE REQUEST TO THE CARTELS.
THE VIDEO FOOTAGE YOU WERE
SHOWING, VERY REAL.
THAT LOOKS LIKE A WAR ZONE, NOT
STREET CRIME.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
>> WE BELIEVE AMERICA NEEDS TO
HAVE THE STRATEGY OF TAKING BACK
THOSE PARTS OF MEXICO FROM THE
CARTELS, HANDING THEM OVER TO
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT.
A LOT OF AMERICANS DON'T KNOW
THIS.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
CONTROL ABOUT A THIRD OF MEXICO.
IT'S NEVER CONTROLLED ALL OF ITS
TERRITORY.
WE SUFFER IN THE UNITED STATES
FOR THAT, BECAUSE THESE QUASI
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES, THESE
CARTELS THAT RUN PARTS OF
MEXICO, AND USE TERRORIST
TACTICS, USE THAT CONTROL OF
TERRITORY TO ARM THEMSELVES,
TRAIN THEMSELVES, THEIR BASES OF
OPERATIONS.
THEY RUN INDUSTRIES OF MAKING
FENTANYL, HEROIN, AND SO FORTH,
AND SHIP ALL OF IT INTO THE
UNITED STATES WHERE THEY'RE
KILLING OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS A YEAR.
A YEAR.
FROM OUR DOORSTEP.
>> Jesse: WE GOT TO STEP IT UP,
DESIGNATE THEM TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEN MAKE SURE
ALEJANDRO NEVER SETS FOOT IN THE
DEPARTME